journée magnifique pour aller ramasser
des feuilles
kazim
willems des canaris en sucre qui c'est
qui va venir se promener avec son débit
mais elle n'est pas là à casimir eu il a
pris le bateau ce matin pour aller
rejoindre sa tante adélaïde il va
revenir propre parfumer les couverts de
bonnes choses et de cadeaux en tout
genre cette tante adélaïde est vraiment
une faiblesse coupable à son égard il
est de plus en plus gâtés heureusement
des deux est futé vous êtes là pour le
ramener à la dure réalité du moc et
parfois ce n'est pas parce que je
l'appelle mon petit canari rose que je
ne suis pas ferme avec clic c'est vrai
vous êtes parfois même assez sévères or
vous trouvez mais que voulez vous je
crois en cette fermeté de l'éducation
traditionnelle
remet mais jules et j'y pense si vous
veniez à sa place avec moi chercher
quelques feuilles
mjd julie julie pour une fois tu as ton
après-midi entièrement libre tokyo ce
qui rend j'étais content des commandes
sont entièrement aux normes et quant à
mozilla j'ai terminé mon travail alors
je te propose d'aller à l'autre bout de
l'île faire la promenade que je te
demande depuis sinon vous exagérez prend
soin c'est moi qui ai fait la
proposition à julie les premières
permettez moi s'il vous plaît de parler
au nom non julie je t'en prie tu ne vas
pas encore une fois de plus me faire
faux bond et je tiens à votre signature
sur mon grand livre d'or écoutez je suis
ravi de vos propositions seulement je ne
suis pas libre cet après midi
ça tu n'es pas les ventes amorcée cet
incroyable jeu mais à la pêche avec le
batteur avec philbert en scène du snob
pas du tout avec léonard
mais alors quand ce n'est pas casimir
c'est léonard but en plus les honneurs
des tests ce lot il a toujours peur de
se mouiller les pâtes et les oreilles eh
bien je ne sais pas mais il m'a demandé
mystérieusement ce matin de
l'accompagner à la pêche aux moules
battre à leur montre bien couverte il
fait frais et de ne rien dire à personne
bravo bravo et danser comme ça que de
garder secret je sais que votre foi pour
mars et les questions
quelles raisons léonard a décidé d'aller
à la pêche aux coquillages je vous
assure une mariani et il ne peut être
vendre le produit de sa pêche et se
faire ainsi un petit peu d'argent de
poche voilà je n'en sais rien mais moi
je vais à la pêche je vais me préparer
je vais chercher les romains au revoir
oui mais je lis je crois que je suis
très bons appuis
voilà deux précautions valent mieux
qu'une alors on dit aussi salins
alors mon appareil photo
manille puis êtes
voilà pour photographier juni mon panier
avant tout est là le so ava voilà c'est
merveilleux c'est tout
je suis prêt qu'est ce que c'est tout
cet équipement mais tu n'as besoin vieux
ton saut et d'un bon couteau pour
décrocher les moules de leurs rochers
tout ça il faut laisser tu sera épuisée
si nous mais je n'ai joué j'avais pensé
que clés tu avais pensé qu'au cas que je
te porterait ton équipement quand tu
serai fatigué il n'en est pas question
elle et ça on va faire des kilomètres à
pied ah bon partout
sans parti nous avons bien fait de venir
je crois que nous allons trouver ici la
clé du mystère
je vous ai suivi par pure amitié pour ne
pas vous laisser tout si nous savons
toujours pas pourquoi mais on a réparti
à la pêche il nous faut trouver un
indice en chasse
pourquoi qu'est ce que j'ai dit si drôle
de chasse casimir est parti à la pêche
je partais en chasse
écoutez décidément francs soit votre
niveau intellectuel baisse de jour en
jour bon écoute et soyons sérieux non je
crois que léonard est parti à la pêche
pour ramasser des coquillages et les
vendre dans le jardin
c'est le foot ce serait une excellente
idée moi j'adore ça
les moules les bigorneaux les traire et
sert à rien d'y penser le mans vient la
bouche pour moi ce que je veux savoir
c'est ce qu'a léonard dans la tête et ça
je le saurai avant ce soir allez vous
chercher de votre côté et moi je cherche
digne
mademoiselle fuite est une vieille
chaussette ça vous intéresse venez
écouter françois sont un peu plus
perspicaces enfin
qu'est-ce que septième essai de calan un
calendrier
et sayah j'y suis c'est aujourd'hui
l'anniversaire de françois et léonard
est parti lui chercher des coquillages
pour les lui offrir
il me faut contre-attaqué
j'ai trouvé un vieux morceau de
saucisson oui c'est très bien pour la
remettre en forme de tour eiffel et puis
quelques boutons on va il va c'est très
bien c'est très bien c'est très bien
et de votre côté mois on orient rien de
rien de très intéressant non vous
devriez retourner dans le jardin et je
vous ai rejoindre tout à l'air d'accord
il faut que je téléphone
allô allô allô marché aux poissons oui
oui bonjour est ce que vous pouvez me
préparer un assortiment de fruits de mer
oui vous ne l'envoyez dans le jardin
l'île aux enfants oui c'est ça merci
beaucoup
valverde
mais me demander mes frères mais quand
ils singent atteint prochain prochaine
ménagères ces penseurs n'hésitant plus à
loin l'on met vautours temps décidons
nous n'attendons plus
regardé ma pêche était tellement bonne
que en voir une partie 1 je ne veux pas
ramener ses pairs du g20 les bigorneaux
qui va mais est rapproché mais belle
daurade draguer la fois on m'a livré
trop de poissons alors je vends le
surplus et je peux comme ça sur mes
lieux léonard ont aimé mon loyer mes
boules à la ménagère voyez ma mourir
d'amour
her home et ne craignez pas comme ça les
honneurs vous me casser les oreilles
approché voyez le moule en a pas trop
cher c'est qu'il m'a dit sur l'approché
approchés à une coquille ah je croyais
que tu l'a rapproché foggia n'a cessé
vous disputez d'ailleurs on ferme le
jard d'arrivée la
douleur d'être le premier à souhaiter
son anniversaire
un françois
lors de coiffer léonard sur le poteau et
de souhaiter son anniversaire à françois
bon anniversaire pour toi quoi
au mi6 vraiment je suis touché que le
premier à voir ton cm souhaité mon
anniversaire je t'ai apporta une bonne
bourriche de fruits de mer car je sais
que tu adores saharouis en effet c'est
une excellente idée j'adore les fruits
de mer merci casimiro
kazemi